you asked an important question at the
top
how do we fix this well what did i say
about the stimulus checks stimulus
checks have 80
approval rating so that's the type of
thing if i was joe biden and i wanted to
actually heal this country
that's the very first thing i would have
done when i came into office same thing
on uh when you look at anything that's
going to increase wages
um i i said on the show i was like look
i think joe biden will have a 80
approval rating if he does two things if
he gives every american
a 2 000 stimulus check and gives
everybody who wants a vaccine a vaccine
that's it it's pretty simple because
here's the thing
i don't really like greg abbott that
much we have like very different
politics i'm from texas but my parents
got vaccinated
really quickly that means something to
me i'm like
listen i don't really care about a lot
of the other stuff
he got my family vaccinated like that
well i will forever remember that
and that's how we will remember the
checks this is a part of a reason why
trump
almost won the election and why if the
republicans had been
smart enough to give him a 2000 another
round of checks
100 would have won which is that people
were like look
i don't really like trump but i got a
check with his name on it
and that meant something to me and my
family i'm not saying
for all the libertarians out there that
you should go and like endlessly
spend money and buy votes what i am
saying is
lean into the majoritarian
positions without adding your culture
war [ __ ] on top of it
yeah so for example what's the number
one concern that aoc says after the
first round of checks got out
oh the checks didn't go to illegal
immigrants i'm like are you out of your
[ __ ] mind
like this is the most popular policy
america has probably done
in 50 years you know since like medicare
and you're you're concerning it you're
ruining it yeah
and then on the right is the same thing
which is that they'll be like these
checks are going to like you know low
level
blah blah you know people who are lazy
and don't work i'm like oh there you go
you know like you're just playing a
caricature of what you are like if you
lean into those issues and you got to do
it clean this is this is what everybody
hates about dc
which is that biden right now is doing
the 1400 checks
but he's looping it in with his coveted
relief bill and all that
that's his prerogative that's the
democrats prerogative they won the
election that's fine
but i'll tell you what i would have done
if i was him i would have come in
and i would have said there's five
united states senators who are on the
record republicans who say they'll vote
for a two thousand dollar check
and i would put that on the floor of the
united states senate on my you know
first or
the first day possible and i would have
passed it and i would have
forced those republican senators to live
up to that vote for this bill
come to the oval office for a signing so
that the very first thing of my
presidency
was to say i'm giving you all this
relief check
this night long national nightmare is
over take this money
do with it what you need we've all
suffered together
the thing about biden is he has a
portrait of fdr in his
in the oval which kind of bothers me
because he thinks of himself as an fdr
like figure
but this is you have to understand the
majesty of
fdr we're talking about a person who
passed a piece of legislation
five days after he became president and
he passed
15 transformative pieces of legislation
in the first hundred days
we are on day like 34 35 and
nothing is passed the reconciliation
bill will eventually become law but it
will become law with no
republican votes and again that's fine
if but it's not
fulfilling that legacy and the urgency
of the action
and the mandate which i believe that
history has handed
it handed it to trump and he [ __ ] it
up right he totally screwed it up he
could have remade america and made us
into the greatest country
ever coming out on the other side of
this he decided not to do that
i think biden was again handed that like
a scepter almost it's like all you have
to do all america wants is for you to
raise it up high
yeah but he's keeping it within the
realm of traditional politics i think
it's a huge mistake why
so this is everything you're saying is
makes perfect sense like take
yeah okay it's like it's like again if
the aliens showed up
it's like the obvious thing to do is
like
what's the popular thing like 80
of americans support this like do that
clean uh also do it
like with like grace
where you're able to bring people
together not like in a
political way but like obvious like
obvious common sense way
like uh just people the republicans the
democrats just bring them together on a
policy
and like bold just hammer it without the
dirt
without the mess whatever tried to
compromise just
the yellow with have a good twitter
account like
loud very clear we're gonna give a two
thousand dollar
stimulus check anyone who wants a
vaccine guess a vaccine
at scale would make america let's make
america great again
by manufacturing like we are
manufacturing
most of the world's vaccine because
we're bad [ __ ]
yeah and without maybe uh with with more
eloquence than that and
and just do that why haven't we seen
that for
many for several presidencies because of
coalitional politics
and they owe something to somebody else
for example
biden has got a lot of the democratic
constituency has to satisfy
within this bill so there's gonna be a
lot of [ __ ] that goes in there state and
local aid
um all this stuff again i'm not even
saying this is bad but he's like
his theory is and this isn't wrong is
like
we're gonna take the really popular
stuff and use it as cover for the more
downwardly
less popular and so the dems could face
the accusation
the people who are on this side this is
their push back to me they're like
why would we give away the most popular
thing in the bill
and then we would never be able to pass
state and local aid right
why would we do that and the republicans
are the same thing right like
mitch mcconnell because he's a [ __ ]
idiot decided to say
we're gonna pair these 2 000 stimulus
checks with like section 230 repeal it
was like oh
it's obviously dead right like it's not
gonna happen together
that's largely why i believe trump lost
the election and why those races down in
georgia
went the way that they did obviously
trump had something to do with it
but the reason why is they have
long-standing things that they've wanted
to get done
and in the words of rahm emanuel never
let a good crisis go to waste
and try and get as much as you possibly
can done within a single bill
my counter would be this things have
worked this way for too long
which is that the reconciliation bill is
almost certainly
going to be the only large signature
legislative accomplishment of the biden
presidency that's just how american
politics works
maybe he gets one more maybe one he gets
a second reconciliation bill
then you're running for midterms it's
over i believe
that by trying to change the paradigm of
our politics
leaning into exactly what i'm talking
here you could possibly transcend that
to a new one and i'm not naive i think
people respond
to political pressures and the way that
we found this out
was david perdue who was just a total
corporate you know dollar jor dollar
general ceo
guy he was against the original 1200
stimulus checks but then trump came out
who's the single most popular figure in
the republican party
he's like i want two thousand dollar
sales checks and all of a sudden
purdue running in georgia is like yeah
i'm
with president trump i want a 2 000
stimulus check
that was if you're an astute observer of
politics to say
you can see there that you can force
people to do the right thing
because it's the popular thing and that
if it's clean
if you don't give them any other excuse
they have to do it
yeah so this is this is what we've been
gaslit into our culture war framework of
politics
and the reason it feels so broken and
awful
is because it is but there is a way out
it's just that nobody wants to be it's a
game of chicken right because maybe it
is true maybe we would never be able to
get
your other democratic priorities or
republican priorities but i think that
the country
understands that this is [ __ ]
terrible
and would be willing to support somebody
who does it differently
there's just a lot of disincentives to
not stay without
there's a lot of incentives to not stray
from the traditional path
yeah is it also possible that
the a students are not participating
like we drove all the the superstars
away from politics
so like you just had this argument
before i mean everything you're saying
sort of uh rings
true like this is the obvious thing to
do
as a student of history you can almost
like tell like
if you look at great people in history
this is what great leaders in history
this is what they did
it's like uh clean bold
action uh sometimes facing crisis but
we're facing a crisis oh we're in a
christ
so why don't we uh
uh why don't we see those leaders step
up that's i mean
you say that's kind of like it makes
sense there's a lot of different
interests to play
you don't want to risk too many things
so on so forth but that's what like
that sounds like the c students i don't
think it's that
i think it's that the pipeline of
politician creation
is just totally broken from beginning to
end
so it's not that a students don't want
to be
uh politicians it's basically the way
that our
current primary system is constructed is
what is the greatest threat to you as a
member of congress
it's not losing your reelection
it's losing your primary right so that
means especially in a safe
district you're most concerned about
being hit if you're a republican from
the right
if you're a democrat from the left for
not being a good enough one
that's actually what stops people more
heterodox people in particular
from winning primaries because the
people who vote in our primaries
are the party faithful that's how you
get the production
the production it's important to
understand the production pipeline which
is that
all right i'm from texas so that's what
i know best so it's like if you think in
texas
if you're a more heterodox like state
legislature
or something who's works with the left
on this and does that
you're gonna get your ass beat in a
republican primary because they're gonna
be like he worked with the left to do
this blah blah take it out of context
and you're screwed
and then that means you never ascend up
the next level of the ladder
and then so on and so forth all the way
but i do think
trump changed everything this is why i
have some hope which is that
he showed me that all the people i
listened to
were totally wrong about politics and
that's the most valuable lesson you
could ever teach me
which was i was like wait i don't have
to listen to these people
they don't know anything actually you
know yeah that's powerful man
like he did it that's exceptionally
powerful this guy even if he didn't
do anything with it it doesn't matter
right
he showed that it's possible exactly and
that
that means uh that means a lot that
means
you're absolutely right there's young
people right now that kind of look
turn around like huh you're like wait i
don't have to comb my hair a certain way
yeah and go to law school
and be an [ __ ] who everybody knows is
an [ __ ] yeah
and and then get elected to state
legislature i mean look
who's the number one person in the new
york prime or new york city
uh primary right now andrew yang he's
polling
higher than everybody else in the race i
look maybe the polls are totally [ __ ]
and maybe he'll lose because of ranked
choice voting and all that but i
consider andrew i mean i know him a
little bit and i've you know followed
his candidacy from the very beginning
i consider him an inspiration he's the
new
generation of politics like if i see
who's going to be president
20 years from now it's going to be i'm
not saying it's going to be andrew yang
i think it's me somebody
like andrew yang outside the political
system who talks in a totally different
way
right just completely one of my favorite
things that he said on the debate stage
he's like
look at us we're all wearing makeup it's
cr you know yeah yeah
and he like he like brought that that he
brought that and
he's writing like yeah why are they're
all wearing makeup probably arguably
hasn't gone far enough almost
yes uh but he showed that as possible
and then
you you see other like aoc is a good
example of somebody at least in my
opinion
is doing the same kind of thing but
going too far
in like well i don't know she's doing
the trump thing but on the other side so
i don't know
what's too far no normative judgment of
it yeah i will tell you the future of
politics
appreciate the art of it right no i do
look i don't i'm not a big aoc fan
but she's a genius media genius once in
a generation talent
the way that she uses social media
instagram and everybody on the right is
like trying to copy her like matt gates
like i want to be the
conservative aoc i'm like it's just not
going to happen dude like it you just
don't have it like what she has it's
like it's electric
and trump had that like i've been to a
trump rally
like to cover as a journalist there's
nothing like it
in america and yang is similar it's the
same way
where you're like there is something
going on here
which is just like i've been to an obama
rally i've been to a clinton rally
i've been to um several normal politics
that's fine you know with trump and with
yang
it was it's another world yeah it's
another world yeah
there's there's probably thousands of
people listening right now who are just
like doing a
yes slow clap yes
uh yang gang uh forever okay but uh
yeah i mean my worst fear i i prefer
yeah uh
uh andrew yang kind of
free uh improvisational
idea exchange all that versus aoc
who i think no matter what she stands
for
is a drama machine creates dramas just
like trump does i would say my worst
fear
would be in 2024 is aoc old enough
it'd be aoc versus trump i don't think
she's old enough i think you'd have to
beat
i think she's 30 so she needs five more
years so probably not
yeah okay but that kind of that that's
or trump jr well aoc probably wouldn't
win a democratic primary so i mean look
joe biden is
you know that's pretty much showed that
that's exactly what you're saying
this process grooms you over time it's
you see the same thing in academia
actually which is very interesting
is the the process of getting tenure
there's this
it's like you're being taught
without explicitly being taught yes
to behave in the way that everybody's
behaved before
i've heard this it was funny i've had a
few conversations
that um were deeply disappointing
which which are which involved
statements like
this is what's good for your career yes
this kind of conversation almost like
mentor to mentee conversation
or it's you know it's like there's a
grooming process in the same way i guess
you're saying the primary process
does the same kind of thing so i mean
that's what people have talked about
with injury yang it was
it was he was being suppressed by a
bunch of different forces the mainstream
media and all
just the democratic just that whole
process didn't
didn't like the the honesty that he was
showing right
now but here's my question to you people
gotta see
look jordan peterson is one of the most
famous people in america right like
you have a massive podcast you're more
famous than half the
99 of the people at mit so like
from that perspective everything has
changed and
somewhere out there there's a student
who's taking notice
and i've noticed that with my own career
everybody thought i was crazy for doing
the show with crystal
the hill they thought it was nuts
they're like what are you doing you're a
white house correspondent you've got a
job
forever the other job offer i had was
being a white house correspondent
and people thought i was nuts for not
just sticking there
and you know aging out within washington
pining for appearances on fox news and
cnn and
msnbc but i hated it i just hated doing
it and i did not
want to be a company man like a
washington man who's one of those guys
who like brags to his friends about how
many times he's been on fox
or whatever mostly because i just have a
rebellious streak and i hate being at
the subject of
other people i created something new
which a lot of people watch
to get their news and i notice that
younger people who are
almost all my audience they don't really
look up to any of the people in
traditional
right they don't they don't go and
they're not coming up and being like how
do i be like jim
acosta you know they're like they're
like hey how did you do what you do and
the way you did it is by bucking the
system
so i think that we are at a total
split point and look there will always
be a path for people
because like i don't want people to over
learn this lesson i have people who are
like i'm not going to go to college and
i'm like well
just wait yeah like i'm like just i'm
starting to play yeah like stop
just like just hold on a second but
there will always be a path for the
institutional
there will that will always be there for
you but now there's something else
now there's another game in town and
that's more appealing to
millions and millions and millions and
millions of people who feel
unserved by the corporate media cnn
and these people possibly who feel
unserved
um in the you know the faculty like if
you are
an up and comer who wants to teach as
many
young people as possible i think you
should be on youtube
right like look at the khan academy guy
that guy created a huge business
so i just think we can be cynical and
like upset about what that system
is but we should also have hope like i
have a lot of hope for what can be in
the future
yeah there's a there's a guy people
should check out so my story is a little
bit different because i basically uh
stepped aside
with the dream of being an entrepreneur
earlier in the pipeline
than like a like a legitimate like
senior faculty
would there's an example somebody people
should check out andrew huberman
from stanford who's a neuroscientist
who's
as world-class as it gets in terms of
like 10-year faculty
just a really world-class researcher and
now he's
doing youtube yeah i see him on
instagram yeah and he's great so he
switched
so he not just does instagram he now has
a podcast
and he's doing he's changing the nature
of like
i believe that andrew might be the
future of stanford
and for a lot it's funny like he's
basically joe rogan is an inspiration to
andrew
and and to me as well and so those
ripple effects and andrew is an
inspiration probably just like you're
saying to these young
like 25 year olds who are soon to become
faculty if we're just talking about
academia
and the same is probably happening with
with government is
funny enough trump probably is inspiring
a huge number of people who are saying
wait a minute i don't have to play by
the rules exactly and i
have to i can think outside the box here
and
you're right and the institutions we're
seeing are just probably lagging behind
so the optimistic view is the future
is going to be full of exciting new
ideas so andrew young is just kind of
the beginning of this
you